La volta al món a peu, dia 290.
Primer dia caminant per Xina.
Bueno, tenim un dia com sempre, cada matí, amb molt bon temps.
Uah! Fuà!
Mira, mira, és que acabo de sortir de la Guescaus
i ja es veu brutalment el Mustang Atta.
D'aquestes tres és el de l'esquerra.
La 47a muntanya més alta del món.
Brutal, eh? Avui sí que es veu.
Però, com a curiositat, es veu que la gent puja a la muntanya
i la baixa esquiant.
He hagut de parar la gravació perquè la dona del hostel m'ha dit
no gravis, no gravis. M'ha fet com un senyal de para de gravar.
Crec que la Xina, i especialment aquesta zona,
això serà una constant.
Hauré d'anar amb compte quan trec la càmera i tal.
De fet, potser ara no és el millor moment
perquè està aquí al costat la frontera.
Bueno, el que deia,
que la gent baixa esquiant
i he de dir que
no sembla una muntanya tan alta.
Diria que és la muntanya més alta que he vist mai.
7.500 metres, jo mai he vist un 8.000.
I home, doncs, jo què sé,
des d'aquí no sembla tan alta.
Estem als 3.700 metres sobre el nivell del mar,
doncs serien...
Són 4.000 metres més, eh?
No sembla que hi hagi 4.000 metres d'elevació
des d'aquí fins al pic aquest.
Però, bueno, evidentment la vista és increïble.
És absolutament increïble.
Bueno, avui toca caminar fins a Trashcone,
que és la ciutat que ja he dit diverses vegades
que és l'última on podré caminar a la Xina.
El que passa és que són 60 quilòmetres
i dubto que el faci tot avui
perquè són les 11 del matí.
Però, bueno, 11 del matí,
hora de Beijing.
Hora de Tajikistan,
que és la que faré servir per guiar-me
de les hores del sol
perquè si no em torno boig.
Són tres hores menys,
per tant són les 8, 8 i pico.
Bueno, no és tan gran.
No és tan tard, tampoc.
Bueno, no sé si acamparé avui o què faré.
Ja veurem.
Però, bueno, la idea és bàsicament
caminar per aquesta carretera
perquè no hi ha alternativa.
Llavors, bueno, anar caminant.
Per sort és tot baixada.
Té pinta que serà un dia força plàcid.
Crec que he sigut una mica massa atonista
en la maniga curta.
I fa fred, eh?
No sé si és que han baixat les temperatures
o és que aquí fa més fred que al Pamir.
No ho sé.
Bueno, ara vinc d'una benzinera
que té una petita botiga
i he comprat alguna cosa.
Primer he comprat xina.
Està estupenda.
Barret.
Bueno, tenen moltes coses rares, eh?
I això que és una benzinera
no és una botiga tampoc molt gran.
Coses que no saps què són.
I jo què sé, per exemple...
Clar, estava una mica emparanoiat
i no he volgut fer vídeo, eh?
Però tenen, per exemple,
una cuixa de pollastre.
Pollastre sembla, potser és ànec.
No ho sé.
Així envasada al buit.
Brutal.
I jo què sé, ja et dic.
Coses que no sé.
Llavors he comprat unes patates
tipus...
Tipus primers.
D'aquests amb aquest paquet.
I després unes galetes
que per anar picant avui
durant el dia
ja estarà bé.
El tio m'ha preguntat d'on era.
He llegit Barcelona.
I em sembla que aquí també
són aficionats al futbol
perquè m'han dit
Barcelona, Madrid...
He llegit Ronaldo.
Ronaldo.
Molt bé.
Què més?
Paisatge de moment
bastant semblant al Pamir.
Amb muntanyes així molt seques.
Però clar, és que...
La pinta que fa tot és molt diferent
perquè veus molta infraestructura.
Veus cotxes que passen.
Veus gent.
La sensació
és molt, molt diferent.
Doncs, mira, gairebé les dues.
13 quilòmetres.
Poca cosa.
Més aviat
avorridot.
Però, home,
dóna gust caminar per una carretera
ben asfaltada.
Les muntanyes molt maques,
però, bueno,
un paisatge així bastant desolador.
He vist algunes vaques.
He vist aquest missatge
que he traduït
i diu
gràcies al Partit Comunista xinès
per la seva feina.
Gràcies al Partit Comunista xinès
I a les regions,
bueno, regions no,
a Shenzhen i Guangdong
per la seva ajuda desinteressada.
Entenem que refereixen
que han fet infraestructures
d'aquesta banda del país
i ho agraeixen.
Una mica raro, no?
Bueno, aquí tenim un cartell
que indica que d'aquí 13 quilòmetres
hi ha un poble que no sé com es diu.
D'aquí 48 quilòmetres
hi ha Trescongar
i a 171 quilòmetres
hi ha la frontera
amb la ciutat de la ciutat.
I aquí hi ha el Paquistan,
que té el nom que no recordo.
Parar d'aquí una mica apartat de la carretera
amb vistes a la muntanya
per menjar alguna cosa i descansar,
que ja porto 3 hores i 23 minuts caminats,
es nota molt
quan és pujada o pla
i quan és baixada.
Normalment 3 hores i mitja
caminades seguides
no les solc fer
i com és baixada,
doncs guai.
Per aquesta zona
sembla que hi ha una mica més de moviment.
Hi ha com un poble aquí,
hi ha com un lloc turístic així
amb una espècie de
construccions antigues,
no ho sé,
les muntanyes molt magues
i he anat a un supermercat.
Ara ja no m'havia acostumat
i a fer temps que no
allò de passar cada dos portes
per un supermercat ja...
ja...
Fes temps que no ho feia.
Doncs mira,
m'he comprat
unes galetes per menjar alguna cosa
i també per demà esmorzar
i un refresc.
No hi havia refrescos dels nostres
de Fanta, Coca-Cola i tal.
Llavors és complicat
haver d'arriscar-se.
Aquest he vist que tenia aquí la llimona.
Ficava Lemon Flavor,
sabor a llimona.
I sí, està bé,
és com una Fanta llimona,
com un Sprite,
amb una mica més de sabor a lima.
Força bé, aquesta l'hem encertat.
Són les cinc
que vindrien a ser
les dues del migdia.
Porto 25 quilòmetres.
Bé, bé, bé, bé.
Està enxil.
Encara queda molt, eh,
per posar-me a campar.
Però estic un pèl preocupat
perquè fa uns quilòmetres,
fa uns 15 quilòmetres,
hi havia molts llocs amagats,
molt bé.
Però ara el que ja són camps,
com veieu,
a una i altra banda,
que tu diràs,
els camps t'agraden, Enric?
Normalment t'agrada campar en camps,
sí, però
si hi ha un dia a la volta d'una peu
que no m'han de veure,
ha de ser avui.
I...
Doncs aquests camps,
doncs clar,
tenen propietari
i suposo que estaran més vigilats
o, bueno,
hi ha les cases al costat,
el que sigui.
Llavors, no sé,
no sé, bueno.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Si a males veig
que no hi ha manera
de trobar un lloc amagat,
el que puc fer
i el que he pensat
és demanar un taxi,
anar fins a Transcongar
i passar la nit allà a un hotel
i tornar el dia següent enrere
i fer els 20 quilòmetres
o els que siguin que em queden.
Això seria l'últim recurs,
però si l'he de fer,
el faré,
perquè no me la vull jugar.
No em puc creure
el que estic veient.
El que estic veient
és el que estic veient
allà.
Què és això?
Són camells?
Camells dromedaris?
Ostres, llàstima
que estan aquí
una mica amagats, eh?
Ho veieu, no?
Quantes xepes tenen?
Dues, no?
Jo veig que a aquest animal
no l'he vist mai.
Allà hi ha un altre,
allà hi ha un altre.
No penso baixar
a fer-los una foto, eh?
No, no.
Ara sí,
ara sí que es veu clar
una mica contra llum.
Què dimoni es fa
aquest animal aquí?
Que guapo!
Mira, mira, mira, mira, mira, mira.
Flipant, tio.
Mira, ara he arribat
a una àrea de servei.
Aquí a la carretera
hi ha un pàrquing,
hi ha restaurant i tot,
però crec que no em paro.
No em paro.
Hi ha moltíssim trànsit,
especialment de baixada.
Que no sigui que la gent
de Tashkongar
treballa a Kashgar,
que és la ciutat que està
no sé quants quilòmetres,
200,
i puja i baixa cada dia.
No sé, hi ha molta gent, eh?
Hi ha molta gent.
I tots cotxes guais, eh?
Bueno,
què?
Estic jo preocupat
per acampar, eh?
No ho acabo de veure clar.
Però bueno,
el dia està sent plàcid.
31 quilòmetres,
ja a les 6 i mitja,
que vindrien a ser
les 3 i mitja tajiques.
Les 7 i 52,
el sol se'n va
a les 21
a...
i 12, per tant,
en una hora i vint.
Abans hi havia arbres
a banda i banda
i els tenen plantats, eh?
Però no estan creixent.
Llavors,
saps?
Els arbres podien cobrir-me.
Ara és tot,
com el passatge és brutal,
hem de ser darrere
la muntanya aquella,
però és que en tenim d'altres.
Maquíssim,
però llocs per acampar
amagats,
complicats.
Bueno, ara,
d'aquí una estona
entro en un congost.
No sé si això és pitjor
o millor.
Si això,
si en una hora no et trobo
per acampar,
doncs he de decidir.
Hi ha una cosa
que he estat pensant,
potser és una idea massa boja,
que és que aquesta carretera
té...
té obres de drenatge
com aquesta,
és a dir,
obres perquè passi l'aigua
per sota
quan hi ha inundacions
o plou molt,
però clar,
no ha de ploure
i...
potser és molt louco,
però...
i ficar-me aquí sota?
Ui, la policia.
Vaig a amagar la càmera.
Doncs...
m'ha parat la policia.
Avui he vist
moltíssims cotxes de policia,
però bueno,
és el primer que em para,
ha parat.
No han sigut només cordials,
sinó que han sigut simpàtics,
o sigui,
en aquest sentit,
molt bé.
Bàsicament,
primer m'han dit
broken english,
anglès macarrònic,
però m'han dit
que he de caminar
per la banda dreta
en comptes de l'esquerra.
Jo he...
no he protestat,
però he dit,
bueno,
és que el meu país
normalment es camina
per l'esquerra
i em diu,
no, però estem a Xina.
Alguna cosa així,
m'ha dit,
estem a Xina.
No és el primer país
que m'ho diuen això, eh?
Fins i tot a Europa
molta gent m'ha dit
camina per la dreta.
Bueno,
ok.
Els xinès en realitat,
pel que he vist avui,
condueixen bastant bé.
He vist algun
endavantament en línia contínua,
però bueno,
no he vist coses boges,
saps,
com Albanya.
Bueno,
i després m'ha dit
Trascon Gar,
no, Bas?
I jo, sí.
Diu,
són 25 quilòmetres
i
et queda una hora de llum.
Doncs no m'ha preguntat
què faràs,
ni
on tens pensat dormir,
ni res.
No sé.
Bueno, en fi,
tinc
diverses opcions.
Opció 1,
fer autostop
o agafar un taxi
fins a Trascon Gar.
Opció 2,
intentar acampar.
Està xungui
allò de acampar,
però bueno,
es pot intentar.
Opció 3,
caminar.
Caminar
fins a Trascon Gar.
Seria
una cosa
és caminar
unes 3 hores de nit.
Són 60 quilòmetres,
porto 38,
per tant,
sí,
queden,
no 25,
queden 22,
però bueno,
sí,
seria arribar
més o menys
a la mitjanit
hora d'aquí,
que seria l'equivalent
una mica a les 9.
Llavors,
m'hauria de pillar a un hotel
i que a l'hotel
m'obrissin la porta
a aquella hora.
No ho sé.
M'estic decidint
perquè
m'estic
en un hotel
m'estic decantant
per aquesta última opció
de fotre la matada
del segle.
Seria la caminada
més llarga
de la meva vida.
M'ho penso,
m'ho penso.
Estic al costat
de la carretera
un lloc
on hi ha
molta densitat arbòria.
També hi ha això.
Vull dir
que algú
que ha vingut per aquí
i veig alguna caca,
no sé si de gos
o de què,
eh...
És bon lloc, eh.
Si estigués a qualsevol
altre país
diria
és un lloc bo.
Aquí a Xina
estic una mica
emparanollat
de que em puguin veure,
saps?
Però és bon lloc, eh.
M'ho penso,
m'ho penso.
Bueno,
al final
em quedo aquí.
No és un mal lloc.
De fet,
a qualsevol altre país
diria que és un molt bon lloc.
Però
en aquest país
estic nerviós.
Estic nerviós.
És que
és molt
difícil
que em descobreixin.
És quasi impossible.
Hauria d'agafar
el frontal
a engegar-lo
i que passés
un cotxe de policia
que veiés
i cridés atenció.
O sigui,
intentaré no encendre llums.
Però,
no sé.
Diria que és un bon lloc,
però
nervis,
nervis.
Primera
i en teoria
última campada
hi ha a la Xina.
Perquè
a partir de trasllogar
tras
tras Congària
no camino.
De fet,
aquest matí
m'he trobat
un mapa
al hostel
a l'Aguèsca
on he estat.
I per si
algun cara
no sap
el meu itinerari
per Xina
que he explicat
40 vegades,
aquí teniu el resum.
Aquí tenim
el mapa de la Xina.
Està
un pèl inclinat,
però bueno,
crec que s'entén.
Aquí tenim
el Tibet,
crec que és això
blau,
d'acord?
I aquí es ponen
vinguts nosaltres.
Llavors,
clar,
aquí està
en xinès,
però bueno,
això és
Teguigistan,
que és per on he vingut.
Aquí tenim
Kyrgyzstan
i aquí
Afganistan,
el corredor
aquest fa bosc,
d'acord?
I aquí
Pakistán.
Llavors,
aquí és la carretera
on jo he d'anar,
la frontera més alta del món,
la frontera amb Pakistán
i Xina.
I he vingut
des de
aquí,
crec.
Per aquí,
és per aquí
el pas de culma.
Llavors,
simplement el que he de fer
és baixar fins a
Traiskongar,
que és aquí,
són 60 quilòmetres,
i aquí hauré d'agafar
un bus
fins a Sost,
perquè no hi ha manera
de creure aquesta frontera
a peu.
Però,
perquè veieu,
és un tram
molt petit.
Aquí tenim
Kashgar,
que és la capital
d'aquesta regió,
que és Xinjiang,
i, bueno,
com podeu veure,
molt, molt, molt, molt,
molt lluny.
Diria que això
és Beijing,
o, bueno,
Pakistà Beijing.
I aquí Shangai
i altres
altres zones
de la Xina.
Però, bueno,
perquè veieu
l'oest que estic, eh?
Estic
molt, molt, molt
a l'oest.
Molt bé,
doncs avui
38 quilòmetres,
no tant,
però, bueno,
m'he trobat aquest lloc
i està bé.
I, res,
té,
no, cafè.
Avui he pres cafè,
sí, pel matí.
Pel matí.
M'he gastat, diria,
que dos euros.
Als supermercats
tampoc he comprat
gaire cosa, eh?
Però
m'ha semblat
superbarat.
Si jo dic que
si vas a unes turístiques
de Xina
o a ciutats
tipus Shangai,
deu ser
preu meus europeu,
però aquí,
bueno,
de moment això.
Avui dos euros,
dos compres
de diverses coses, eh?
No només
un parell de cosetes.
No, a la
perdó,
a la gasolina
també m'he gastat
això.
M'he gastat.
Doncs posa-hi tres i mig, va.
Posa-hi tres i mig,
al final tres compres.
Avui
no he parlat amb ningú.
Bueno, sí,
amb els dos
amb els dos britànics.
I, res,
ha sigut
un dia
molt estrany,
molt estrany
perquè
per una part
dius, ostres,
estic a la Xina, saps?
Per l'altra banda
ha sigut tot el dia
carretera,
però ha sigut un bon dia, eh?
He fet bon temps,
aquesta
acampada,
la policia
que m'ha parat,
un dia una mica
de tensió,
les muntanyes
espectaculars,
el paisatge molt maco.
Ha sigut un dia
molt estrany,
molt estrany.
Però, bueno,
tu,
ja està,
ja està.
Vinga,
demà
arribo a
Tashkongar,
21 quilòmetres.
També serà interessant
veure aquesta ciutat.
Bona nit.